[APPLAUSE]
ADDY OSMANI: Hello.
So we all care
about performance.
Keeping our pages fast.
Making sure that we're
using just the right amount
of memory.
How many people here have used
the Chrome DevTools before,
to try figuring out if they have
a memory leak in their route?
How many people here have
enjoyed that experience?
Right?
There's like one person.
Get out!
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
No.
So I've been working with
the DevTools for few years.
Memory profiling, using
our memory tools--
they're fantastic,
but at times they
feel a little bit
of a black box.
And so in this talk we're
going to look a little bit
at understanding how memory
profiling works in the DevTools
give you some pro
tips on that stuff.
We're also going to do a deep
dive into some V8 specifics
to help you understand how
things like the memory graph
work.
It's hopefully going to
be interesting but-- yeah.
Whenever I'm building
an app that I
think this is going
pretty well, I'm
pretty happy with
the performance,
half the time I end up
in this situation where
I've got this really
nice, smooth performance,
and then someone
comes in and crashes
into that nice feeling
like a plastic tractor.
That is what a memory leak
feels like to me half the time.
So I've been
getting a few emails
from some friends that had a
few memory profiling issues.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to take a look
at some of those emails
and try to figure out how
to solve these issues.
So let's go and open up
the DevTools on this page.
Now, what's the first issue?
Paul writes in saying, "Why
is my memory usage growing?
My app slows down when
I click on this button.
Why is that happening?"
So the first thing you can
do-- before we actually go
and open up the DevTools--
the first thing you
can do, if you think you
have some sort of issue
to do with memory in
Chrome is actually
going to open up
the Task Manager.
So the Task Manager is actually
hidden in the Tools menu,
So you can go to Tools
and Task Manager.
What this will do
is actually give you
a list of all of the currently
open tabs and extensions
that you have, and it will
list right next to them
the current memory
usage, CPU usage.
You can actually go and if you
right click on the top here,
you can also expand
it to show the GPU
memory, JavaScript memory,
shared memory being used.
And this is useful for just,
like, getting a hint about
whether you've got
growing memory in a tab.
So in this case, we could go
and try to find the mail tab.
If I go and I click
on this button--
might have to drag this window
a tiny bit-- what I'll see
is that, yep, memory
usage is growing
in this tab at the moment.
That's useful for
a very simple hint.
But what I want is
some more specifics.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to open up the DevTools.
Head on over to the Timeline.
And I'm now in Memory view.
Technically speaking, this is
Frames view and memory view.
Just make sure you've got the
"Capture memory" option on when
you're trying to
work on this stuff.
So Memory view is really useful.
If you haven't used
it before, it's
great for tracking the total
number of objects allocated
in memory, seeing
whether they've grown,
looking at the total
number of DOM nodes
that have been allocated,
how many documents have been
created, event
listeners allocated.
So here, I've clicked on my
button, and if I go and look
here I can see that the memory
usage on this page is growing.
It's not growing too much.
It's growing a little bit.
But I can actually go
and slice down this data,
try to see what's going on
in a particular segment.
In the bottom view, where
you see the Memory pane,
you can take a look at the
size of the JavaScript heap,
whether that's growing.
Again, the documents, the nodes.
Right off the back of
that, we've actually got
another question
that was sent in:
"Where does GC-- so where
does garbage collection--
fit in with memory profiling?
I'm trying to look at the
time spent by the GC."
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to click on "Start
creating chunks,"
and go and start
recording, and I'm
going to explain a
workflow for tracking down
if you've got a memory issue.
So normally, if you think that
you have a leak, after you've
taken a look at
the Task Manager,
try to identify a
sequence of actions
that you think might be
leading to that leak.
So maybe it's clicking
on a button that's
going to show more
images in a carousel,
or clicking a
button that's going
to display more
content in your page.
So identify the
sequence of actions
that's suspected of leaking.
Go and record a Timeline
like we're doing right now.
And then the next
thing you want to do--
and this is pretty important--
is use the trash icon.
So there's a trash icon here
that says, "Collect garbage."
What this is going to do
is basically force GC.
If you don't click this
icon, what's going to happen
is that the objects
that you have in memory
are going to stay alive
until the next round of GC.
It's not a massive
deal, but it just
means that you're going to be
waiting a while before you're
going to be able to get
a proper profile of this.
Now, if you iterate a few times
and you see a sawtooth curve,
it might mean that
you're allocating
a lot of short-lived objects.
What I mean by a
sawtooth curve is
something that looks a
little bit like this.
So pay attention to what's
in the red rectangle
at the very top.
So that's a sawtooth curve.
If you see something that
looks a little bit like this,
it means you're allocating
lots of short-life objects.
And if that sequence isn't
expected to retain memory--
so if you're not doing
anything too intensive
and your DOM node count
isn't actually dropping--
it might be an indication
that you're leaking.
So keep that in mind.
Let's take a look at the
next question we have.
So we've got another
question in here.
This one's from Jake
Archibald: "Addy, buddy, pal.
I'm letting you find and
fix a memory leak in my app.
Also, please send a PR
with the fix to my repo."
That's Jake.
Right, so we just
learned about how
to go and try to memory
profile something.
What we've got here is what
looks like we've got some tabs
and we actually
have a slider that's
just displaying some images.
This is like a carousel, so
it's displaying different images
based on the seasons.
We've got one for autumn,
summer, winter, and spring.
Nothing overly complex.
Now we're going to do
here is, Jake thinks
that he has a memory
leak in his app.
I'm actually going to
reload the page in case
any of the objects
from our other examples
are still hanging around.
I'm gonna clear that.
And what we're
going to do here is
we're actually going to go
and use the object allocation
tracker in DevTools
tools to figure out
if we have a memory leak.
Now the object
allocation tracker,
let's actually go
and record this.
So I'm just going to
click on "Start here."
Start interacting.
Now the object
allocation tracker
basically takes heap
snapshots periodically
throughout a recording.
The bars that you're
seeing here, the blue bars,
basically mean new objects.
And the height of
these objects basically
correspond to the
size of the objects.
So something is getting
sort of turned into gray,
it means that we don't have
to worry about it anymore.
If it's staying blue, we do.
So I'm going to stop
just there, and let's
try narrowing down one
of the thicker bars
and see what's going on here.
So I'm going to select a
segment, maybe a larger segment
then we've got at the moment.
Let's take a look here.
We've got DOM token list.
You've got attributes,
a node map.
Let's try to expand
it to the whole set.
And what I see here is that
I've got HTML li element, so
the list element, that
may be causing trouble.
So this is, basically--
How many people
here have used the heap
snapshot tools before?
A small number of people, OK.
Basically, what the
object allocation tracker
is doing in the
background is it's
taking a bunch of
different snapshots
and it's basically
leaving behind stuff
that hasn't been
correctly cleaned up.
So here, what we
can see is that we
have a number of
different list elements.
And if I go and I
dive down into here,
what you'll see in the retaining
view at the very bottom
is we've got a few
different objects.
We've got HTML document, details
element, HTML div element.
What I see here is a reference
to a variable name called
"last div."
And if I actually
hover over this,
I can scroll down in
this information bar
and see that the
innerHTML actually
seems to be some of
the content for one
of these carousel items.
Now if I go over
into my sources view,
and we actually
go and take a look
at the source for this
particular example--
I'm gonna try bumping up
the font size a little bit
so people can see it.
Let's actually run through the
functions that are called here.
Whenever I go and
select a tab, it's
calling this function called
"select tab," which is then
going and calling load content.
Let's scroll down
to load content.
We can see this
doing two things.
It's calling "prepare
content," which
happens to be referencing last
div, so maybe that's leaking.
And it's also calling
"prepare gallery."
Now if we scroll down
a little bit further
and we take a look
at prepare gallery,
let's take a look at
what's going on here.
So here's probably where all
of our different list elements
are coming from, so
it's gone and it's
tried to query those in the DOM.
Then we scroll down
a little further,
and what notice is that
basically every single time
Jake is selecting
a new tab, he's
actually going and setting
"interval" on this animation.
But he's not clearing it.
So that's going
to end up causing
a leak if we continue doing it.
One thing he could do
here is probably go
and actually-- if we scroll
down we can see the fix.
If he just went and
actually assigned
a variable for that
timer, for that interval,
we can go clear
it up when we know
that it's no longer necessary.
Otherwise, we're going to end up
with a copy of prepare gallery
with everything that
comes inside of it--
its elements, its function
definitions-- in memory
on every single click.
So we've looked at that.
Let's move on to
another example.
Let's go back to the timeline.
So Matt Gone asks, "What
are scattered objects?"
Scattered objects are
basically something
that we mention in our docs.
You may or may not have
come across before.
I'm going to go back to
profiles for a moment.
Clear this stuff up.
Reload the page very quickly.
And I'm going to go and
record a heap snapshot.
Let's just record a heap
snapshot very quickly.
And now let's record
one after I've
clicked the "Create
scattered objects" button.
Do a comparison
between these two.
Sorry, I've got to
expand this a little bit.
Now one thing that you might
run across in your applications
is you might have objects that
are basically the same kind
but which happen to be
scattered across different parts
of your application.
So you might be using the same
class in different modules,
for example, or across
different plug-ins.
Now one of the nice things
about the heap profiler
is that it'll actually aggregate
all of the different instances
for that particular
type of item.
So in this case, our class is
actually just called "item."
And it'll just aggregate
them all into this nice view
so we can go we can
just drop down and see,
OK well, this is
where I have all
of the different
instances of "item."
To just give you a
little bit of insight
into what the code
there is doing-- we
have two functions here.
Both of them are
using the item class.
This is a very
simple item class.
Both of them are
using the item class.
But in the profiler
view, I can actually
just get a nice, simple
way of drilling down
to exactly those instantiations
that I'm interested in.
Let's take a look
at another example.
So this is an example
from Paul Lewis, it seems.
Paul, do you want to come
up to read up your email?
PAUL LEWIS: No. [INAUDIBLE].
ADDY OSMANI: I would never
do anything like that!
Not to an esteemed
colleague like you, Paul.
You're coming up to do this.
Right so.
PAUL LEWIS: Hi!
ADDY OSMANI: Hi!
This is your section.
This is the email
that you wrote me.
PAUL LEWIS: That's harsh.
Today I walked into the
gym and did one push-up
in front of everyone.
Then ripped off my shirt.
Of course I did, why wouldn't I?
And I walked out
grunting, "You did it!
You did it!"
Anyway, I'm trying to understand
what I see in heap snapshots.
Help?
ADDY OSMANI: I didn't
embarrass you in any way.
PAUL LEWIS: No, that
sounds totally legit.
ADDY OSMANI: Not
in the slightest!
Maybe you'll do a push-up later.
Right.
So Paul's wondering about how
we can find detached nodes
in the heap snapshot view.
So let's go and create--
let's take a clean snapshot.
And then let's take
a snapshot after I've
clicked on the "Create
detached nodes" button.
Let's go and record that.
Let's go to the comparison
view, because we
want to compare what happened
between those two snapshots.
Right.
And if we go and take a
look at HTML div element,
what you'll see is that we
have a number of elements here
which are highlighted in red.
If I go I select
one of them, you'll
see that we have
other nodes that
are mentions in this
detached DOM tree
lower down on the page,
which happen to be in yellow.
Now there's a little
bit of a difference
between the red nodes
in the yellow nodes.
Red nodes don't actually
have any direct references
from JavaScript to them,
and they're usually
alive because they're still
part of some detached DOM tree.
There might be a node
in the tree that's
referenced from JavaScript,
maybe as a closure,
or from a variable.
But it's coincidentally
preventing the entire DOM tree
from being garbage collected.
The yellow nodes--
so again, those ones
that are the very
bottom-- do have
direct references
from JavaScript.
So look for those yellow nodes
in the same detached DOM tree
to locate if you have
a leak of some sort.
And we can go and we can
actually clean that up
by clicking on the "Clean
detached nodes" button.
I'm not going to show you
that, but I will give you
the demos later on, so
you can check that out.
Eric writes in and
he's asking, "How
does memory work with
V8 hidden classes?
Someone told me if the compiler
can use hidden classes,
your code will
execute much faster
and will use much less memory.
Is this true?"
OK, so let's try to do that.
Let's go and create
a new heap snapshot.
Let's clear.
Create a new heap snapshot.
Create some objects.
Do another recording.
So this is taking a while.
We're creating a ton of
objects here in the background.
So it's still collecting
and parsing that data
and building up the tree.
So we go and we
take a look here.
And what you'll
notice is that we
have two classes that are of
particular interest to us.
We have slow purchase
and fast purchase.
Now, I'm going to
expand this a little bit
so you can see all
of the data here.
Now, slow purchase
has a retained size
that is significantly larger
than the retained size
of fast purchase.
If we take a look at our
page once again, actually,
and I go and do some
calculus, which is basically
just performing
the same operation
with those two classes--
just one of them is slow
and one of them is
fast-- what you'll see
is that fast is actually pretty
significantly faster than slow.
Let's go and try to
explain that a little bit.
So V8's optimizing
compiler makes
a lot of assumptions
about your code.
It transparently,
in the background,
creates hidden classes
representing your objects.
And using those
hidden classes, V8
is able to work a lot faster.
If you do things like
delete properties,
those assumptions
are no longer valid
and they can end up
causing de-optimizations
behind the scenes.
So in this particular
case, what we
see is we have a fast object
and a slow object Functionally
speaking, these two classes
are very, very similar.
The only difference is that in
the case of the slow object,
I thought I'd be
really clever, I
thought maybe the
slow object would
be faster if I actually
deleted a property.
It's actually using
less memory, right?
Maybe?
I don't know.
And so we delete this
property from our object.
But what actually happens is
that causes V8 to actually bail
out of using its hidden
classes for optimization,
and it makes things
significantly slower.
Actually any where
up to 15 times
slower in the case of
this particular example.
So although I'm saying try to
be careful when using delete,
you're almost certain to find
it in many popular JavaScript
libraries.
It certainly has a
place in the language.
There are valid uses of it.
But the main takeaway
here is to avoid
modifying the structure of
hot objects at run time.
So in this case, what we
probably should have done,
instead of using
the delete key word,
is just nullifying the object
so that it could be properly
garbage collected.
Because only when the last
reference to an object
is removed does that object
get properly eligible
for collection.
Great.
So let's go and take a
look at another example.
Before we go on
to closures, let's
take a look at leaky DOM nodes.
Rob Dobson writes in,
saying, "I suspect
that I have an array leaf
nodes which might be leaking.
I'm not quite sure
how to find this."
Well, the workflow
is actually very
similar to what we've
been doing here before.
I'm actually going to, once
again, refresh the page.
Normally, when you're doing
any sort of memory profiling,
you probably want to start off
with what we call a clean room
testing environment.
What that means is that you
should be working in a brand
new user profile, without
any extensions enabled.
Incognito is OK,
but there are still
extensions that you can
end up running there,
and your extensions
can end up actually
impacting your
performance scores.
So regardless of whether
you're doing memory profiling
or you're trying to
take a look at what's
going on with your
frame rate, make sure
you're generally working in
a clean testing environment.
So here what we're
going to do is
we're going take
some heap snapshots.
So I'm gonna take a
snapshot before this action.
Go in, create some nodes.
Take one right after.
Take a look at the comparison.
And if I scroll
down here, let's see
if there's anything of interest.
So at the very
bottom, you can see
that we have our
detached DOM tree.
Now, you're probably
going to be doing
this on a much larger
screen if you're at work,
but it's usually
good to actually
have DevTools fully open.
Like, on a second screen,
so you can take a look
at all the details here.
But if we expand the
detached DOM tree here,
what you'll notice is
that the leaf nodes
array that Rob was talking
about is actually visible here,
so it is in fact leaking.
You take a look at the sources
for what he's doing here,
and-- I'm not sure
which example this is.
I guess this one. -- Actually,
I've got I've got some slides
on this.
So this is to do with DOM leaks.
So what we have here is a
graph that basically talks
about a page containing
a parent div,
with the ID tree, and a child's
a-link with the ID "leaf."
And if we walk through
what's happening here,
what you'll see is that,
well, first of all,
just going and selecting
"tree," we're selecting "leaf."
We're selecting "body."
We're, first of all, trying
to remove a reference to tree.
We're thinking,
OK, well, normally
you'd imagine that actually
cleans up everything.
But tree isn't able to get
properly garbage collected,
because tree ref is actually
still being referenced up here.
And so to fix that, we
set tree ref to "null."
Now unfortunately, it
still can't be correctly
garbage collected at that
point because there's
an indirect reference
to tree from leaf ref.
So you see here we're still
trying to reference something
that is a part of tree so
you have to also set leaf ref
to null in order
for this entire tree
to be properly
garbage collected.
Let's take a quick
look at closures
before we dive into
some more V8 stuff.
So Paul asks, "How do
I analyze the impact
of closures on memory?
I'm lazy.
Can I have explanation or demo?"
All right.
How about I give
him an explanation?
Right so, closures
are pretty powerful.
They enable us to use inner
functions to retain access
to outer function variables,
even after the outer function
is returned.
Unfortunately,
closures also happens
to be excellent at hiding
circular references
to JavaScript objects and DOM
objects, which can sometimes
be something that
leads to memory leaks.
So if you're using
closures, just
make sure that you
understand what references
are retained inside the closure.
In this particular case,
we have three examples
of more or less
something very similar.
But we happen to be using
"eval" in the very last example,
and we're passing
through an argument
to our function in
such a way that there's
going to be constantly a
reference to our large string
or anything that is
passed [INAUDIBLE] there.
That is going to make it
very difficult for that
to be properly cleaned up.
Your inner functions
and your closures
usually need to
be able to access
all the variables for
the outer functions,
meaning that as long as
a reference to it exists,
variables from
the outer function
can be correctly
garbage collected.
And so they'll continue
to consume memory,
and so after those
functions have completed,
invoking, which might
mean a memory leak.
So just be careful
with closures as well.
So we've covered DOM leaks,
we've covered closures.
Quick tip to do a timer.
So timers can also
be something that
are a little bit
tricky to deal with.
Anything you're doing
repetitively, inside a timer,
can be anything
that is left running
for quite a long time, that you
need to be pretty careful with.
If you've got something like a
slide show that loops forever,
just make sure nothing in
the slide show itself still
maintains references to DOM
objects that could accumulate
leaks if they
happened to be GC'd.
I wanted to quickly
mention ES6 WeakMaps.
Has anyone here heard
of WeakMaps before?
Or used them?
Awesome.
Right, so the idea here is
that we have basically two
ways of defining private
member data for a class.
We have two-person classes.
They're basically
doing the same thing.
This is your typical
classical example
of having a nodule with
private data on public data.
So a person has a closure that
captures some private data.
And that private data--
so, in this example,
on the left where we
see our private data,
so you see that VAR privateData?
That is basically
a strong reference.
The garbage collector is only
able to collect an object
if there are only
weak references to it,
or no reference to it at all.
The WeakMap version
of this-- so,
WeakMaps are basically
something that come in ES6.
The WeakMap version
holds keys weakly,
and that basically means
that the person instance
and its private data are
eligible for garbage collection
when a person object is no
longer referenced by the rest
of the application it's
basically just a new type that
helps us avoid memory leak
situations a little bit more
easily than we have with ES5.
Just an example of where the
language is trying to help you
avoid shooting
yourself in the foot.
So we've walked through
some very quick demos.
I've got a little bit of
a cheat sheet for you.
Some people are
really stoked whenever
they hear that there are
cheats available for something,
so maybe you'll be
excited about that too.
So this is the
way that I usually
approach any sort of memory
profiling or performance
optimization.
Design first.
Code from the design.
And then profile the result.
What this is all about
is simple designs
are usually easier to optimize
if you follow this pattern.
Sometimes profiling
can reveal problems
that you don't find
when you go and do
things like premature
optimization.
Premature optimization
is definitely
the root of all evil.
Whatever you take away from
this talk today please make sure
you're trying to make sure that
your code and the solutions
to your code make as much sense
as possible first before you go
and try designing
for performance.
You can always apply those
performance optimizations
the very end.
So don't let performance
considerations
affect the design
of a piece of code.
That can sometimes result in
code that is not as visually
pleasing to look at and
deal with as is possible,
because you were complicated
it with the optimization.
So here's my memory checklist.
The first thing you
need to ask yourself
whenever you think you
might have a memory issue
is, "Is my app using
too much memory?"
The timeline memory view
and Chrome Task Manager
can help you identify if
you're using too much memory.
Remember that memory
view gives you everything
from tracking objects that are
allocated, to live DOM nodes,
to JavaScript event listeners
and the inspected render
process.
"Is my app free
of memory leaks?"
Use the object
allocation tracker.
Object allocation tracker can
help you narrow down leaks,
looks at the JavaScript object
allocation in real time.
You could also use
the heap profiler
to take heap snapshots,
analyze memory graphs,
and compare snapshots to
discover what objects are not
being cleaned up by
garbage collection.
"How frequently is my app
forcing garbage collection?"
If you're GCing
pretty frequently,
you may be allocating
too frequently.
So use the timeline memory
view once again just
to help you identify pauses
that are of interest.
There are some good rules
that you can follow.
Avoid long-lasting
references to DOM elements
you no longer need.
DOM leaks really suck.
They can sometimes be a
little bit tricky to discover.
But as long as you're keeping
an eye on any references
you're making to elements,
and especially when
you're in loops, you're
making sure to either nullify
those references
when you're done
or not make those references
in the first place.
That that's even better.
Properties of objects
like DOM objects
might contain references
to other objects
or JavaScript objects they
contain references to others.
That can end up causing
circular reference
issues that can lead to leaks.
V8 is really, really
awesome at getting around
some of these issues
for you, but it's always
good to just keep
these in mind when
you're developing your apps.
Better than de-referencing,
use local scopes,
unbind events that
are needed anymore,
so unbind those event listeners.
Be careful when you're
storing large chunks of data
you're not going to use.
So this is
particularly important
when you're looking at anything
like storing data offline,
storing data for a
temporary user session.
Make sure nothing
really large gets cached
that you don't want to cache.
Make sure that your caches don't
accumulate forever, and have
an aging mechanism to
get rid of old objects.
Because a lot of time
and you can end up
catching large sets of
data that the user is never
going to need to
reuse once again.
So just be careful
with that stuff.
Manage your local
cache adequately.
So we've been looking at a
little bit of DevTools stuff.
I'm going to spend a
little bit of time talking
about the conceptual material
of how JavaScript manages memory
in V8.
To explain some of the stuff
that we saw in our demos.
For anyone that hasn't
quite grokked it yet:
why does perf matter?
Well, first of all, we
care about delivering
silky smooth apps.
Everyone wants happy users
and silky smooth apps
can help us get there.
We want longer battery
life, smoother interactions.
We want our apps to
live as long as possible
without having to worry
about them crashing.
Nothing is free.
So the fastest
page-- does anyone
know what the fastest
page on the web is?
Anyone at all?
It's about blank.
That is the fastest
page on the web.
Anything that we
add on to that page
actually is making it slower.
So nothing is free.
Use tools like the
Task Manager to keep
an eye on what
resources you're using,
because you're always
going to end up
paying some price
for those resources.
If you take a look
at this, these
are some stats from last year.
Google apps-- so things
like Gmail, Docs--
spend about 50 to 70%
of our time in V8.
A lot of popular sites spend
somewhere between 20 to 40%
of their time in V8 on
JavaScript app distribution
time.
So it's still an area that.
If you end up having leaks, is
worth actually optimizing on.
As Nat covered in his
talk, most the time
we're trying to hit
60 frames a second
in our apps to deliver on
those smooth experiences.
That basically gives
us 16 milliseconds
to get everything done in.
So for Chrome's
workload, we're looking
at 16 milliseconds for
dealing with loading data,
parsing HTML, dealing with the
layout of the page, JavaScript
execution.
Anything that ends
up slowing that down
is going to result in your
user seeing pauses and jitter.
And that's going to basically
mean them seeing jank.
Right?
So jank manifests itself when
you blow your frame budget.
If you are able to
complete within that time,
you're going to end
up missing your frame,
and your animations are going
to end up seeming sort of janky.
So visually slow to your users.
We don't want that.
Blow your memory
completely and you're
going to end up seeing the
"He's dead, Jim" message.
The friendliest message ever.
Which basically means that the
operating system has terminated
your tab because it's
run out of memory.
Again, something that
we don't want to happen.
And we can prevent by
avoiding memory leaks.
Whenever it comes to the
performance versus memory
battle, we've
always got one side
the says, "You can always
throw more memory at a problem.
You know, I don't need to
worry about memory leaks
because I'm just going to
add another 16 gigs of memory
to my system."
Right?
But unfortunately,
the reality is
that this isn't a
problem that can just
be solved by throwing
more memory at it.
You think about your grandma,
that maybe has a Chromebook.
Maybe that only has four gigs
of memory on it, or 8 gigs,
or whatever it is these days.
That has significantly
less than your development
system at work that has 32 or
64 gigs of memory, whatever
it is you crazy kids have today.
But whenever it comes down
to the old age performance
versus memory trade-off,
offer performance.
Let's try to get it
great for everybody.
So let's take a look at some
memory management basics.
So here's what we're
going to be looking at.
We're going to look at the
types of values that there are.
How values are
organized in memory.
What is garbage?
And actually define
properly what is a leak.
So JavaScript variables
can be four primary types.
We have Boolean, number,
string, and objects.
So the Boolean type is
really just true or false.
You guys already know that.
Number type is basically
any double position floating
number.
You've got the string, which
is a UTF-16 encoded character
array.
And then you've
got your objects,
which are like a key value map.
Right?
So those are the
four primitive types.
Objects are built around
key value mapping.
The key goes into
the square brackets,
and this is always a
string, unless you're
talking about ES6
maps, which allow
you to have non-string
keys, but we're not
going to talk about that.
No matter what you put
into those brackets
it's going to end up being
coerced into a string.
And then you use that as
sort of a look-up table.
And then for that value,
you can store basically
any JavaScript object
inside of that value.
So think of memory as a graph.
The memory graph is a
pretty fundamental concept
when it comes to trying
to understand how browsers
handle JavaScript performance.
So think of memory as a
graph with primitive types.
So those numbers, those
strings, those objects
we were talking about.
It could visually be
represented as a graph
with a number of
interconnected points that
look a little bit like this.
So we're looking at a whole
bunch of circles here,
and lines on this side.
But let's start from the
left of the blue circle here.
So the root node.
This is the root object that's
inside the memory management
system.
It's not something you can
explicitly manipulate or do
anything crazy with.
But this is just where every
object you create descends from
and it's also called the root.
From that root it
references global variables.
The red objects here
are object variables.
So those can reference
other variables.
And the green
circles are scalar.
Scalar variables.
Like a Boolean, or
a number, and that
can't really reference
anything else.
And you can see the green
node at the very end here.
I'm not sure if my
cursor is visible.
That green note at the end here
at the upper part of the screen
is basically the
terminating node
in this part of
the object graph.
So objects have a concept
of a retaining tree.
This is the path
along the graph that
are keeping the object from
being classified as memory.
So on this side
right now you can
see that we have a green
node over here in the center.
Let's look at its retaining
tree for this green node.
So the retaining tree
for this green node
is this yellow node right
here, the root node.
As well as this other
path from the root
to the other yellow
node, and the other
actually has to pass through it
or it can get pinned in memory.
If both of those
paths are terminated,
then the object becomes
garbage collected
and it's eventually
correctly collected up.
So what about removing
a value from that graph?
Well, this is a fairly
basic operation.
It is sort of
important to understand
how you can remove a
value from a graph.
So if we want to
remove the red value,
so this value at the
very end right here--
if you want to remove
that from the graph,
we could cut this edge right
here from the root node
to the first green node.
And then the red
value becomes garbage.
If we cut this edge
it's also garbage.
Or we cut this edge.
Basically, any of
these edges cut
would make the red node garbage.
And that brings us
on to that question
of, "What exactly is garbage?"
Right?
Well, it's all values that can't
be reached from the root node.
Or, if we say it
another way, it's
all values that are
lacking any sort
of retaining path in the system.
So if something doesn't
have a retaining path,
then it becomes garbage
like these nodes
that you see right here.
So you'll see that here
there's no path from the root
nodes, these values.
So these values are
properly garbage collected.
What about garbage collection?
At the next garbage
collection process
for these nodes that
we're talking about,
they're going to be
cleaned up, and that
brings us to try to explain
what garbage collection is all
about.
The first step in
garbage collection
is to find all of the
live values in the system.
The second is to
return the memory used
by the dead values
back to the system
so they can be
recycled later on.
As we see here.
And there they go.
What about a value's
retained size?
So another property that
basically every value
inside of JavaScript has
is its retained size.
So the retained size you could
probably conceptually think
about as the amount of
memory that would be free
if the value went
and became garbage.
And if so, that's the size the
value and its descendants would
lack retaining paths.
And so if we look
at the yellow node
on this graph, its retained
size of this new yellow node,
is both of the green
node size plus itself.
And if we go all the way
back to the root node,
the retained size is
all of the memory that's
being used by your JavaScript.
Which takes on to, "What
is actually a memory leak?"
Well, a memory leak
is something that's
existed in basically any sort
of computer system ever created.
But the idea is that
it's a gradual loss
of the available system memory.
It occurs when you've
mistakenly left a retaining path
to some value
inside of that graph
that we were talking about.
So JavaScript web
apps can usually
suffer from similar
memory-related issues
that you'll see in native apps,
mobile apps, Android apps.
Leaks to do with bloat, but also
to do with garbage collection
pauses.
So you might think that
the value has no path here.
So a value that erroneously
still has a retaining path
is something we need
to be concerned about.
So you might think of the
value has no path, starting
from the root node,
getting to it,
and that will be collected
on the next round of garbage
collection.
But you're occasionally
and accidentally leaving
a retaining path.
And so you end up
with the situation
of having a memory leak.
So if we take a look at
this really simple example,
it's a little bit
Gmail-themed, where
we've got this email
message and we're basically
appending it to a list.
So we have an email object.
We have this message
field inside of it.
We assign that to a
div node in the DOM,
and we then want to display
these email messages,
so we add that div node into
the display list as well.
So this is what the
object graph looks
like after running this code.
So that's a very
simplistic piece of code.
This is what the object
graph looks like for it.
So we're starting
at the root node. .
There's paths to both
email and display.
And then off to email,
there's a path to message,
and there's this special
kind of edge from the message
through to the div node.
And this is pinning
a native object,
so I'm trying to
highlight that there.
That's pinning a native object,
an external object that's
not directly related
to JavaScript,
but it just looks
the way it does.
So maybe the
programmer is trying
to go and clean up
this list of messages
and they'll do something like
display.removeAllChildren.
And you think, OK, maybe
all these divs are gone.
Maybe I don't have to worry
about this problem anymore.
But whoops!
Something has gone wrong!
We've actually managed to cache
a reference from the message
object to the div node.
And so until the email
itself is removed
from the system-- which
could take forever.
We don't know when that's
actually going to happen.--
The div node is going
to be pinned to memory
and we've leaked it.
Imagine this happening on a
system of a great scale, where
you could have hundreds of
messages being loaded up
at the same time.
It could easily
escalate to a point
where you're leaking so
much memory that you're not
able to create new tabs, or your
current tab ends up crashing.
So some memory management
basics that we've covered.
In general, the basic idea
is that memory management
in JavaScript, and all of
values organized inside a graph.
So remember the graph?
They can have retaining paths.
Any value that lacks a
retaining path becomes garbage.
And then there's retained sizes,
and that's the amount of memory
that you're going to
free up when the value
itself becomes garbage.
Let's go from the general to the
specific and talk about the way
that V8 manages memory and
what happens during a GC pause.
We're then going to
talk a little bit more
about DevTools tools
and just summarize
some of the tools that are
going to be useful for you
in your day to day workflow.
So the first
question you usually
ask yourself is, "What
is the cost of actually
allocated memory in JavaScript?"
And surprisingly,
it's not the "call
to new"-- so going and creating
a new instance of class.
It's actually not that.
Typically, the call to new
is actually pretty fast.
It's gotten much
faster in recent years.
It's really fast
until you've gone
and you've exhausted
your entire memory pool.
And we'll get to this
in a moment, what's
actually happening.
But at that point
the runtime is forced
to go and do a
garbage collection.
And this is where all
the time is spent.
It can actually
take milliseconds.
So remember, if you're
trying to write a 60 fps app,
and you've only got 16
milliseconds to do everything
in, a garbage collection pause
might pause your application
for five, maybe 10 milliseconds.
Which for Gmail might
be OK, but for some apps
it's really too long.
As Nat mentioned, GC
pauses have become
less of an issue
in recent years.
But again, it's just something
that's useful to be aware of.
So the next thing
we're going to cover
is the young generation and
old generation concepts in V8.
So V8 manages memory
in two generations.
There's the young
and there's the old.
The young generation
will probably
be telling you, "Get
to the chopper!"
And the old generation
will be telling you,
"Get to the walker."
That's terrible.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
That's the only terrible
joke I'm making today.
Right.
By young and old, what
do I actually mean?
Well, by young and
old, I mean how long
has the JavaScript value
existed for in the system?
Over time, young values end up
getting promoted to old values,
so after a few
garbage collections,
if the value of an
object survives--
meaning there's a
retaining path and it's
kept in memory-- eventually that
value ends up getting promoted
to the old generation.
So as you can see,
young values end up
getting translated into
old values over time.
So what are the properties of
the young generation in V8?
Well, it offers really
fast allocation.
So young Arnie.
Really fast allocation.
It's frequently collected.
In fact, if you're using
the DevTools Timeline
you can usually see
the GC event on,
so if you hover over one of
those bars in the timeline
you can actually
see the GC events,
and dive down into some more
information that will give you
some insights that
can be useful.
So those will give you some
hints on young generation
collection.
Then we've got the
old generation.
In contrast, it
offers fast allocation
but the collection is
usually a lot slower.
The good thing is that it's
really infrequently collected,
and some of the old
generation's collection
occurs in parallel with
your page's execution.
So whereas the young
generation is really
just-- everything is stopped,
your collection occurs,
then your page resumes--
the old generation mixes
a little bit of collection
with your page's execution.
I'm mostly going to be focusing
on the young generation
here because that's
where you're going
to feel the pain
inside your apps.
And it's going to
happen pretty regularly.
So let's try to cover it.
So it's important
to understand why
collecting the young generation
is a little bit faster.
Intuitively, you
usually have to end up
understanding that the
cost of the GC pause
is actually proportional to
the number of live objects
that you have in memory.
Because objects get split
into the young generation
and the old generation,
young generation
actually doesn't
survive very long.
So after a round of
garbage collection is run,
most of the values in
the young generation
don't actually make it.
They have retaining path,
because they're just
used briefly, short of
short-lived objects.
They don't exist anymore.
They're not really in the graph.
Whereas, by their nature,
objects in the old generation
have usually survived
quite a long time.
So you can't expect when
a collection is triggered
for the old generation that many
of them are going to disappear.
They're going to be around
for quite some time.
So knowing the cost of the
garbage collection pause
really comes down to the
number of live objects.
And it becomes quite clear why
collecting the young generation
is so much faster.
So let's take a look at the
young generation in action.
So here the young generation
is split into two semi-spaces.
There's the To space
and the From space.
Now the To space is where
values that you allocate
from your page get
executed, like the new fu.
It's coming out of the To space.
And the From space actually
just sits there not really
being used until much later on.
We'll see what happens
with it in just a second.
So assuming that the To
space started off empty,
and your page starts
allocating objects,
so let's say that we're
we're going to name them
something simple, like A, B, C,
D. Let's look at the allocation.
So we go and we allocate
A, and then B, and then
C, and finally D. And
everything up until this point
has been really, really fast.
And there's been no interruption
to your page's execution.
But then your page goes
and it calls new E.
And actually, it's just too big.
It doesn't fit
into the To space.
We've hit a threshold
in out system
where we've moved incrementally
closer to this GC pause,
and now we've
actually triggered it.
So we've got to pause
inside of our app.
So what happens is that
new E doesn't happen.
It's kind of paused.
So we're still in
this state where
we just have A, B, C, and
D inside of our To space,
and the page is paused.
Everything halts and the
collection is then triggered.
So the first step in a
young generation collection
is that the From and the
To spaces get swapped.
The labels to them
get flipped internally
and the live value
is then found.
I'm not going to go into too
much detail about this part
of the system, but
everything that
still has a retaining
path on the graph
is discovered, and then
marked for copy at this point.
So you can see here
that A and C are marked,
and B and D have not been
marked, so they're garbage.
They're not going anywhere.
And this is most of where
our time ends up going.
It's where the live
values end being copied
from the From space
to the To space.
So here we are.
We've done the copying,
we've done the collection,
we've just copied the live
objects from one semi-space
to the next.
And there's no other work
to be done at this point.
It's just ready
for the next time
there's a garbage collection
around that needs to happen.
And at this point
your page is resumed
and the object E is
allocated, so it's then
able to actually do something.
So quick summary.
What you have to understand
is that each allocation in V8
moves you closer to a
collection, so a garbage
collection round.
The trade-off we
talked about earlier
between more memory
and performance?
You start to see why
that doesn't quite
hold up inside JavaScript.
Because the more memory
you use, the faster
you're going to get
to this actual pause.
That's actually
where you're going
to end up losing performance.
So just try to take
some care there.
Not only that, but the
more memory you're using,
the longer that pause
is going to take.
And the larger the heap,
the longer the collection
is going to take
to actually occur.
So remember,
triggering a collection
pauses your application.
So when the collection
occurs, your app gets paused,
you get higher latency.
Let's say the user
is going and clicking
the inside the application.
Well, that click isn't going
to register for a while,
because we've got to
do this big collection.
This is the is the place to
drop frames per interaction,
and in general, unhappy users.
And unhappy users are going
to end up going somewhere else
and you don't want that.
So let's take a quick summary
of some of the performance tools
that we have available to us.
So what the performance
memory API does
is it gives us a
great tool for doing
in-the-field measurements.
So it gives you
back three values.
It tells you the
JS heap size limit,
which is the total
amount of memory
available for JavaScript.
It tells you the
total JS heap size,
which is the amount
of memory that's
been allocated so far,
including the free space.
So this is including
memory that has already
been garbage collected.
So you could predict
the "I'm dead, Jim"
message by seeing when total JS
heap size hits the JS heap size
limit.
And as the total
JS heap size starts
to get closer and closer,
you know that at some point,
you're going to trigger this
and end up out of memory.
And finally, it gives
you used JS heap size.
That basically tells
you the amount of memory
that's currently being used
by live objects in the graph.
So let's quickly summarize
some of the stuff
that we learned today
in Chrome DevTools,
and hopefully this is
going to be stuff that's
going to be useful to you
in your day-to-day jobs.
So DevTools memory timeline, we
showed it earlier in the talk.
It shows you everything
from parsed JavaScript,
to calculated styles,
garbage collection pauses.
In the frames view it'll
show you everything from pane
to composite.
We're mostly interested in
the memory side of things,
so it will show you
total allocated memory,
live DOM nodes, number
event listeners.
Don't forget that
you can force GC
from the DevTools
using the trash icon.
That's a really important
step people always miss.
This is something
we automatically
do for you if you're happening
to use one of the profilers.
In timeline it can be
useful to force a GC too.
Memory distribution.
Heap snapshots are
really useful for that.
So once you've confirmed
that a problem exists, go
and try taking
some heap snapshots
and dive into the
nitty-gritty of what's
going on inside
your application.
We let you switch between
a number of different views
of the data that's available,
so we've got three views.
We've got Summary, which
groups by constructor name.
Comparison, which
I use a lot, which
compares two different
snapshots together.
Containment view,
which gives you
a bird's eye view of
the object structure.
Don't forget the difference
between these two colors.
So yellow objects have
JavaScript references on them.
Red or detached nodes,
they reference from one
with the yellow background.
Reading results, the DevTools
Docs curve of this stuff
pretty well.
We're running out of time.
So distance is the distance
from your GC roots.
You've got retained
memory, which
is memory used by
all of your objects.
The objects they are
referencing, as well.
Use it to know where you're
using most of your memory.
You've got shallow size.
Even small objects
inside your application
can hold large amounts
of memory indirectly
by preventing other objects
from being disposed,
so just keep an
eye shallow sizes.
You've got constructor.
So we try to group
all the objects
in the retaining tree by their
type, so keep an eye on those.
The retaining tree
shows you information
that will help
you understand why
objects aren't being collected.
Quick tip.
If you happen to
be using closures,
please try to name them, because
those will actually show up
in the heap profiler, and
it will be really easy
for you to go and detect them.
So in this case we've got two
examples where, at the top--
I know this is a little bit
hard to see-- at the top,
we're basically saying
var LC equals function,
which is not a name function.
In the bottom, we're
saying var LC equals
function LC, which
is a name function.
The second one will show up as
a labeled thing inside the heap
snapshot.
So you can easily
stay on top of that.
Profiling memory leaks.
Some of you may be familiar with
the "three snapshot" technique,
which we've had in the
DevTools Docs for few years.
We've recently retired
that technique.
The basic idea
there was that you
started from a steady
state, and then performed
a number of different
snapshots and compared
what happened between
those snapshots
to understand whether
or not you had a leak.
What we replaced that with
over time-- I'm sorry,
I'm just skipping through
this because of time--
but what we replaced that
with is the object allocation
tracker I was showing
you earlier on.
Basic idea with the
object allocation tracker
is that we give
you a way to avoid
having to repetitively take
snapshots yourself to find out
if you have a leak.
So the snapshot, the
allocation snapshots,
can be recorded from the
record heap allocation
section of profiles.
It combines the detailed
snapshot information
that you see in
the heap profiler,
with the incremental
updating in real time view
that you get inside
the Timeline panel.
It's really useful to use and
I'd definitely check that out.
You can read more about the
trackers inside of our Docs.
Remember that blue bars
mean memory allocations.
Taller means more
memory being used.
Gray bars mean that something
has been de-allocated.
You can trim down by time.
You can take a look
at the heap contents
quite easily to dig
into more information.
Very quickly, I'm going
to start wrapping up.
Something new that we introduced
in the Canary DevTools
is allocation stack traces.
This is a brand new concept.
We haven't talked
about it before.
But the basic idea
here is that you can go
and you can enable
this in settings
in the Canary DevTools,
under record heap allocation
stack traces.
And it just makes a profile
and collects stack traces
when you're going and recording
your heap allocations.
So once you've gone and
you've recorded a profile,
you'll see that we
actually give you
a new tab next to
the retainers view.
And the stack trace is going
to be missing for many objects,
but if it happens,
it just means that it
was created by V8 internals.
It just gives you
some more information
that you can use
during debugging.
I'm going to gloss
over very quickly.
Flame charts.
How many people here have
heard of flame charts before?
Right, so, half of you
have heard of flame charts.
If you're trying to visualize
JavaScript execution over time,
flame charts are really useful.
You go and trigger them by
recording a new CPU profile.
If you go and try to select
the Chart view inside of that
but that'll basically give
you this really gorgeous view
that provides a
visual representation
of your JavaScript
processing over time.
You can actually dig down
to individual functions
and see how much
time they took up.
And by analyzing
and understanding
your call progression
you can visually
gain a better understanding
of the execution
within parts of your app.
So the height of these actual
bars isn't really significant;
they just represent function
calls which occurred.
What is important is
the width of those bars.
You can take a look at more
of the stuff in our docs.
Is optimization actually
worth the effort?
I'd actually say
yes, I think it is.
I know that I've been throwing a
lot of stuff at you guys today.
There's been a lot of stuff on
tooling, a lot of stuff on V8.
This stuff is actually
worth knowing about.
This is a graph from
Gmail's memory usage
that we took over
a 10-month period,
using the performance
memory API.
And what we discovered, if you
take a look at the very left,
is that you see that
memory was actually
really out of
control at one point.
The green line is the median
and the blue line corresponds
to the 99th percentile.
You can see the for
our power users,
using the tools that
I showed you today,
we were actually able to reduce
memory footprint by up to 80%,
if not more.
And for our average
users, we were actually
able to reduce their footprint
by 50%, which is kind of huge.
So for long-life
applications like Gmail,
being able to narrow
down memory leaks,
being able to squash them
down, is actually a big deal.
If you do end up having memory
leaks in your applications,
I hope that you'll take
a look at our docs,
you'll learn the tools, try
to use them on your own apps.
There are a bunch
of resources I'm
going to link you up to later.
There's some good
case studies that
have been done by
everyone from Imager
to Drupal to StrongLoop
to other people
who've been looking at
memory leaks in JavaScript
and how they apply
to everyday apps.
Last thing to remember.
Ask yourself these
questions if you
think you have issues
with your apps memory.
How much memory is
your page using?
Is your page leak free?
How frequently are you GCing?
Know your arsenal.
Make sure that you know
the profiling tools
inside of things like Chrome,
regardless of whether it's also
looking at the Firefox
dev tools and other dev
tools that are out there.
To know your arsenal.
Hopefully at least one or
two people in this room
are excited about the
idea of having a better
grip on memory profiling.
Maybe some of you are just
excited this talk is over
and you get to actually eat.
But overall, I hope that you
at least got something out
of this talk.
That's it for me.
Thank you.